printemps dernier le Technocentre
Renault a ouvert son nouveau bâtiment
entièrement dédié à la simulation de
conduite immersive ce centre abrite
notamment le plus grand simulateur de
conduite du monde roads installé dans un
hall dédié ce nouvel outil devrait
permettre une meilleure conception mais
également une accélération du processus
de développement des véhicules Renault
pour en parler je suis aujourd'hui en
compagnie d'Olivier Colmar directeur
ingénierie transformation digitale
simulation numérique et PLM bonjour
bonjour alors tout d'abord est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer à quoi va servir
ce nouveau bâtiment alors on a construit
ce bâtiment spécialement pour notre
nouveau grand simulateur roads on en a
profité pour regrouper d'autres
simulateurs qu'on avait déjà au
Technocentre et puis les équipes en
charge de ces simulations immersives ont
été implantées dans le bâtiment moderne
et complètement fonctionnel qu'est-ce
que R qu'est-ce que c'est ce plus grand
simulateur du monde alors rose c'est un
c'est un élément important pour nous
dans la conception comme vous le savez
de plus en plus on utilise de la
simulation numérique et donc cette
simulation numérique nous permet de
faire des simulations de crash
d'aérodynamique d'acoustique de
simulation des différents systèmes entre
eux mais toujours les résultats sont
obtenus avec des équations des courbes
et cetera un véhicule c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est aussi des
critères subjectif et donc on a besoin
d'un simulateur pour remettre l'homme
dans la boucle on va pouvoir à
l'intérieur de ce simulateur reproduire
des véritables scènes de conduite donc
on va pouvoir reproduire des routes
évidemment du trafic plus ou moins dense
on va pouvoir ajouter des voitures des
camions des vélos euh des piétons mais
on va aussi pouvoir faire varier les
conditions météorologique on va pouvoir
créer du brouillard de la pluie des
conditions compliquées comme de la neige
on peut faire faire varier les
conditions d'adhérence de la route et
puis donc en gros faire un peu des scèes
accidentogène tout ce qu'on veut et puis
le le deuxième point très important
c'est qu'on va pouvoir aussi agir sur le
véhicule numérique que l'on conduit donc
on va pouvoir changer des paramètres
changer des réglages et éventuellement
faire tester au conducteur différentes
configurations pour voir quelle est la
configuration quelle est la solution
technique qu'il préfère donc en gros
plus besoin de d'avoir une voiture
physique et de faire les simulations
exactement exactement donc on on est
capable pendant les phases les les les
phases de développement de la voiture de
tester notre véhicule sans construire de
prototypes physique sans aller sur des
vraies pistes on est complètement
indépendant de la météo et on peut ainsi
concevoir avec robustesse et puis faire
que quand on on fera le premier
prototype physique on a quelque chose
déjà de très abouti et qui ira très vite
en production auprès de nos vrais
clients l'idée c'est de de de pouvoir
très très en amont tester nos futurs
véhicules en quoi est-ce que c'est une
avancée technologique considérable alors
c'est c'est une première mondiale
pourquoi d'abord par la je dirais la
taille du de du moyen que nous avons
développé le simulateur roads se déplace
sur des rails de 25 m par 25 m c'est à
peu près 90 tonn en mouvement donc on
voit que c'est quelque chose d'ampleur
et puis en terme de performance c'est
aussi une è mondiale puisque simulateur
est capable de reproduire des
accélérations supérieures à un
G on peut complètement s'immerger dans
le véhicule puisqueà l'intérieur du dô
on a un vrai véhicule un système de
projection à 360° et le conducteur a
vraiment l'impression de conduire un
véhicule avec les sensations
d'accélération de roul et de tangage
merci beaucoup merci à vous